Welcome back everyone
We just found out that Andrew
Garfield will be coming back to the MCU,
paying off his teaser from Spider-Man
No Way Home that he
Tobey Maguire Spider-Man.
Tom Holland's Spider-Man would do this
again sometime and hang out together.
So we'll break it all down.
And what the plan is for his character
going forward.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we have.
Loki Season
two episodes coming up after Ahsoka
and those will connect with the larger
Avengers Kang Dynasty Secret Wars plot.
Also point out Easter eggs and connections
in the upcoming Marvel movies
and shows as we see them.
some of the stuff will not be super
connected to the larger sequel or plot,
some of its more earth based stuff
like Captain America four, for instance.
there's also a cool bit of news
that Lord and Miller might be in talks
with Marvel to do Avengers
secret words in after watching Spider-Man
across the Spider-Verse.
I definitely think that
they could handle a story
that big with that many characters.
and speaking of bringing characters
from Sony's Spider-Man movies to Avengers
Secret Wars in live action,
I'm actually hoping that instead of
doing the Thor core from the more modern
secret wars, they actually do
the Spider society and we get to see
live action versions of Spider-Man
2099, Spider Gwen and Miles Morales.
connecting things back
to Andrew Garfield Spider-Man.
Of course, he had a short cameo scene
during Across the Spider-Verse.
He'll probably have a bigger one
during Beyond the Spider-Verse
in a couple of years, along with Tobey
Maguire and Tom Holland's Spider-Man.
lot of versions of Spider-Man
coming back in multiple movies in the next
few years, like a whole lot of Spider-Man
all over the place.
Andrew Garfield.
Coming back to the MCU is primarily
for Avengers secret wards.
There was a new report that Kevin Feige
had begun the process
to actually get him back in a bigger role
for secret Wars, just before everything
shut down for the strikes.
Could you, would you do it again?
Do you would you put the suit on
if given the opportunity?
you know, never say never.
I mean, it's such it's a character
that's always going to be so meaningful
to me and so beautiful to me.
And again, it comes back to service.
You know, I think
if there's a way, because that's what
that's what that character is all about.
He's all about serving the greater good
and serving his fellow
fellow people, his fellow, you know,
serving humanity and all life, you know.
So if there's a way for me to
continue to add to the legacy
of that character in a way that feels
like it's of service
to an audience, of service,
to the themes that,
you know, the themes that Stanley kind of,
you know, injected that character with.
I'm open
and of course, I'm very, very open.
nobody can do any work on
pretty much any movies at all
that haven't already been written
or filmed.
That's why some movies
are still coming out this year
and they're still doing visual effects
work in publishing.
Other movies like The Marvels
is still coming out in November
because they don't need new actors
or new writers for that film.
They're past that stage But supposedly,
Marvel fired both of its writers
for Avengers 5
Kang Dynasty in Avengers 6 Secret Wars.
So if you didn't like Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Madness or Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantumania,
that's good news for you
because the writers from
both of those movies
were doing Kang Dynasty and Secret Wars.
since they were fired, a lot of the plot
will probably change for both movies, but
some of the big beats will stay the same,
typically for bigger Avengers movies.
If you haven't heard about this before,
Marvel started visual effects
work about four years in advance.
That's what they did for Avengers
Infinity War
in Avengers, Endgame They worked on both
those movies at the same time.
So when they announced Infinity War
and released that
first big teaser with the Russos
just hyping the movie up,
another team at Marvel had already started
working on the very final battle scene
for Avengers Endgame.
That's how long it took to complete
that final battle scene.
that's one of Marvel's tricks
for getting movies out so fast
is that they preplan
what some of their major battles
are going to be before
the actual script is written.
Visual effects for big battles
just take so long to complete.
The sooner they start, the faster
they get the movie out.
But. As you would guess, it
causes a lot of problems for them
later on too, especially with the script.
Like how they make things connect.
They already have this giant battle scene
planned out in made So at least right
now, even though the script for Secret
Wars will completely change, for example,
they already know what the final battle
is going to look like mostly,
and they'll just tune things
with a few minor
character changes later on
if they aren't able to get certain actors
to come back
or they decide to change who's in that
final battle later in the process.
For instance, Nova was in a version early
on for that final battle
in Avengers Endgame, but obviously
they swapped Captain Marvel in for him.
macho man, Russo brothers.
How do you guys not have any Nova Corp
member in a fight against Thanos?
Love the movie, but just boggles my mind.
Didn't even have to be Richard writer.
I look closely at that scene again there
and you will see
there are thousands of people.
Yeah, you will see Richard Writer
in the background
of a shot Easter egg Right.
Now, both Kevin Feige and Sony separately
have been trying to get Andrew Garfield
to come back as his amazing Spider-Man
for multiple different movies.
Kevin, Fire and Marvel just want him back
for Avengers secret wards.
That's mostly what this video is about.
The stuff he'd be doing in
Secret Wars is totally different from
why Sony wants him back.
Sony has like a billion Spider-Man
spin off movies they're releasing.
It's more Ben
time all over the place for them,
and they want a live action Spider-Man
to put in all those movies.
Tom Holland does not want to do
5 billion Spider-Man movies.
He even just took a longer break
from acting last year just to give himself
time to chill out before they start
working again on Spider-Man four.
Sony has to find
another Spider-Man to use,
and they're not quite ready for live
action.
Miles Morales At least not until
after Spider-Man beyond the Spider-Verse.
And that's been delayed
until at least 2025.
It could be even longer.
lot of people want to see Sony
make Amazing Spider-Man
three for Andrew Garfield.
There have been a lot of reports
they tried to get him to come back,
but they tried.
Operative word.
right now,
it seems like he's only going to come back
for secret wars
in Spider-Man beyond the Spider-Verse.
But during those he's
doing two completely different things.
during Spider-Man,
beyond the Spider-Verse,
his cameo seemed to just be a larger
live action version of his cameo
seen from across the Spider-Verse.
Pretty simple setup.
Same for Tobey Maguire and Tom Holland.
the main reason
why you didn't see bigger cameos from them
in across the spider-verse
was because of the whole plot
revolving around the spider society
trying to hunt down Miles
Morales and trap him.
And there's no way that
their three versions of Spider-Man
would be totally cool with that.
they even kind of
just did a version of that in Spider-Man
No Way Home with Doctor
Strange, trying to pull the same trick
with Tom Holland's Spider-Man
and prevent him from saving the villains
in Spider-Man across the Spider-Verse.
It was just Miles
trying to save his father
that they were trying to prevent
The plan right now for secret wars
is to assemble a multiverse.
Team of Avengers
is made up of sort of a whole of team
of legacy characters from older movies
like the X-Men movies, Fantastic Four,
the other Spider-Man movies like Tobey
Maguire, Andrew Garfield movies,
before they fired the current writers
of both those movies, The Loose plan
was to have a new version
of the MCU Avengers Form and Kang Dynasty
and Fight the Council of Kangs
or the Dynasty Kangs,
whatever they're calling themselves right
now, They're meant to lose.
Like the Council of Kangs
will be too powerful to many of them.
Their technology is vastly superior to
the New Avengers, so they have no chance.
this might have changed in the last
couple of months with all the delays,
but they wanted initially to make
their secret wars be a totally new plot.
Loosely based though,
on the classic eighties secret wars
in the more modern version of secret wars.
at the end of Avengers 5 after
the Avengers have gotten their asses
handed to them
a version of the Beyond who might wind up
being another type of King variant.
We'll see about that.
before all the drama.
The rumor is that it was going to be
the king who they thought man had killed.
He survives, returns with God
to your power, kills the Council of Kangs,
fulfilling his promise during quantum
mania like
that was the first thing you wanted to do
was kill the rest of the council, then
collapses the multiverse like destroys
all of reality to create battle world.
And you have a bunch of survivors,
but they're all from different universes
in Marvel's plan was to say
that most of the survivors, or just all
these legacy characters from the old Fox
Marvel movies, the Sony Spider-Man movies
and Doctor Strange from the MCU has
to assemble in Avengers team with them.
they eventually wind up
defeating the beyond
or bringing everyone back
and remaking the multiverse,
but do so with some minor changes,
allowing them to sort of soft reboot
things, fold in
whatever changes they want to explain how
X-Men are all over the place in the MCU.
The 616 universe going forward.
that's why you're hearing all this
talk about them soft rebooting
the MCU with secret wars,
their whole separate video about that.
So we'll link it at the end of this
and down to the description below,
The whole idea is that Andrew Garfield's
Amazing Spider-Man will be a big part
of that multiverse Avengers team,
like a slightly bigger part
than he had in Spider-Man.
No way Home.
Same idea for Tobey Maguire to
This would allow Kevin Feige
to payoff all the things,
the ideas that he had for crossovers years
and years ago that that at the time.
He couldn't pull off for legal reasons
or he didn't have enough juice of the time
or enough bargaining chips
or there's just too many lawyers involved.
Now. He can do whatever he wants
with any of the characters for instance,
back in the day,
the X-Men movies wanted to
have a crossover between Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine and Tobey Maguire Spider-Man.
this was going to happen in the Tobey
Maguire Spider-Man movies.
But when it came time
to actually do the cameos,
they had a problem with Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine suit, so they couldn't
actually do the cameo at the time.
But now there's none of those problems.
They can do all the crossovers
that they want.
So the idea is that Avengers
secret wars will mostly be made up
of anonymous
Q versions of the characters coming back.
They might split secret Wars
into two movies.
If they do that, then we'd see more
MCU characters in Part two, probably.
Let me know in the comments.
Where else do you want to see
Andrew Garfield?
Spider-Man come back in the movies either
MCU movies or the Sony Spider-Man movies.
My Asoka Episode three video will post
after they release this week.
We should get a new Loki Season two
trailer really soon to be sure
to enable alerts from my channel
so you don't miss those click here
for my Ahsoka Episode three video.
I think the link, as soon as I post
that and click here to learn
why Marvel is rebooting the MCU.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!